[Música]
1916 solo 13 años después de que los
hermanos wright volase en el primer
aeroplano más pesado que el aire nacía
una empresa americana dispuesta a
revolucionar la recién nacida industria
de la Aviación fundada como la Pacific
aeroprodox y renombrada apenas un año
después como Boeing esta empresa
encadenó éxitos durante décadas y
desarrolló algunas de las mejores
tecnologías y muchos de los mejores
aparatos de cada momento desde el primer
avión comercial moderno el Boeing 2-47
lanzado en
1933 hasta el icónico Jumbo 747 Boeing
ha sido capaz de sorprender a la
humanidad durante décadas hasta que
llegó ervus
Pero antes antes de meternos de lleno en
el tema de hoy es un hecho se acerca al
verano si vives en Madrid no te tendré
que convencer demasiado y no es el
verano acaso la mejor época para
aprender un nuevo idioma con el que
poder comunicarte en tus viajes o
incluso pillar un curro veraniego en el
que hables con turistas Pues atentos
porque en Babel han diseñado un método
pensando en ti con sus audios y podcast
Babel se encarga de darte todas las
herramientas para que puedas darle un
empujón a ese idioma que siempre has
querido dominar sin tener que trastocar
tu día a día mientras paseas al perro
viajas en metro compras en el súper
cualquier momento es bueno para aprender
con Babel y no solo eso también cuentan
con recursos como juegos reconocimiento
de voz clases culturales y por supuesto
lecciones Según tu nivel déjate de
excusas echa un ojo a los 14 idiomas que
puedes aprender con Babel Escoge el que
más te motive y Aprovéchate de un
descuentazo de Hasta el 50%
con el enlace que te dejamos en la
descripción y ahora sí continuemos
90 años después del lanzamiento del
icónico Boeing 2-47 hoy el mundo de la
Aviación es radicalmente diferente
Boeing no solo ya no lidera el mercado
sino que ha sido superado por un
competidor con casi la mitad de años de
vida airbus fijaos en este gráfico lo
que veis es una guerra muy reñida un
mercado repartido entre dos grandes
colosos donde sin embargo airbus está
ahora llevando la delantera en la mayor
parte de los últimos 20 años la europea
airbus ha registrado más pedidos que su
rival norteamericano La pregunta es por
qué cómo es posible que los europeos
hayan logrado batir a la Poderosa
industria de la Aviación comercial
norteamericana quizás muchos estéis
pensando que este cambio tiene mucho que
ver con el fiasco del Boeing 737 Max un
avión que como ya sabéis estuvo 20 meses
en tierra Porque las autoridades de
seguridad aérea le prohibieron volar
tras registrarse dos mortales accidentes
Y sí en cierto modo esto tiene mucho que
ver con lo ocurrido Al fin y al cabo el
7 Max era la gran esperanza de Boeing
aunque no vamos a profundizar mucho en
esta cuestión porque aquí en
visualpolitik Ya hicimos un vídeo
íntegramente dedicado a este tema os
dejo el enlace al final del vídeo pero
esa no es la única razón que explica
porque airbus ha logrado adelantar a sus
rivales estadounidense en este caso la
historia viene de mucho más lejos
[Música]
nunca os habéis preguntado cómo diantres
una empresa de aviones europea logró
ponerse a la altura en calidad y
tecnología del Gran líder americano que
controló esta industria prácticamente
desde su nacimiento Cómo nació airbus de
Quién fue la idea y por qué se creó
Quién ha puesto la pasta para que
consiguiera mirar de tú a tú a Boeing y
quizás la pregunta más importante de
todas qué demonios tiene que ver todo
esto con visualpolitik queridos amigos
amigas la historia de airbus y su guerra
con Boeing es más que una historia de
competencia entre dos empresas es
también una historia de competencia
política Estados Unidos versus la Unión
Europea el viejo gigante contra el nuevo
mastodonte y creedme si os digo que hay
mucha pero que mucha tela que cortar
Esta es una historia que va mucho más
allá de la propia Aviación así que qué
me dices estás preparado tienes los
cinturones abrochados pues esperemos
[Música]
la unión hace la fuerza
la segunda mitad del siglo XX fue la
época de la explosión económica y la
modernidad tanto en occidente como buena
parte de Asia y también fue la época en
la que Europa se levantaba de las
cenizas de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
donde Antes había peleas y conflictos
constantes ahora de repente había
acuerdos y cooperación De hecho si esto
no hubiera sido así probablemente airbus
jamás habría existido
amigos la empresa aeronáutica europea
por excelencia nació en 1970 fue el
resultado de una negociación política
entre gobiernos que ya había empezado
unos cuantos años antes sí tal cual como
lo escucháis airbus no fue una
iniciativa que surgirá de algún
empresario visionario ni nada por el
estilo la idea salió de los despachos de
los propios gobiernos de Francia y de
Alemania occidental a finales de los
años 60 para lograrlo estos gobiernos
propiciaron la unión de la aeronáutica
francesa aeroespacial y La alemana deuts
airbus más tarde se unieron al consorcio
las empresas aeronáuticas de España y el
reino en esencia la idea era replicar la
colaboración que habían hecho los
franceses y los británicos para crear el
Concorde unos años antes pero en este
caso con el objetivo de crear una
estructura a largo plazo que permitiera
hacer aviones digamos menos exclusivos
aviones que primero tenían que ser
capaces de llenar un hueco en el que las
americanas Boeing y McDonald's que
acaparaban cerca del 80% de todo el
mercado no tenían ningún producto y más
tarde competir con ellos directamente a
gran escala y así es como el primer
aparato en hacer fue el airbus a 300 que
fue el primer avión de fuselaje ancho en
hacer vuelos comerciales con dos motores
bajo las normas etops y del cual Por
cierto ya os hemos hablado en nuestro
canal hermano mega projects si os
interesa la historia de este avión pues
os dejo el enlace en la descripción pero
no nos desviemos y pongámonos en
situación
[Música]
con los europeos fabricando aviones
modernos y ganando poco a poco cada vez
más mercado gracias a la unión de varias
empresas Boeing tenía que hacer algo así
que en 1997 trataron de replicar el
modelo adquiriendo a su competidor
directo americano la McDonald's sin
embargo con esta compra el gigante
americano heredó algunos de sus
problemas entre ellos económicos y de
cultura corporativa que tarde o temprano
le pasarían factura
sea como sea el caso es que había
empezado la era del que quizás es el
duopolio más importante y poderoso de
todos los que puedan existir el de la
Aviación ahora bien no vayamos tan
rápido Esta es una industria que
requiere de muchísima inversión en
capital es decir que para que funcione
hay que poner mucha pasta como os podéis
imaginar pues diseñar desarrollar y
fabricar aviones no resulta nada pero
que nada fácil La pregunta es quién iba
a poner la pasta para desarrollar la
tecnología que les permitiera a cada una
de las dos empresas intentar conquistar
el mercado mundial por primera vez voy
tenía enfrente suyo a un potencial
gigante capaz de mirarle de tú a tú pero
cómo competirían exactamente cómo
pretendían los europeos Conseguir
eclipsar al gigante norteamericano pues
veréis insisto para lanzar un nuevo
programa para crear un nuevo avión hacen
falta sobre todo dos cosas La primera es
dinero montones y montones de dinero
pero para que os hagáis una idea más
clara de lo que estamos hablando
pongamos un ejemplo concreto
echemos un vistazo al caso de la 380
derbus el avión de pasajeros más grande
del mundo que se dejó de fabricar en
marzo de 2021 cuando salió de fábrica el
último aparato Pues bien fijaos
el programa del a380 que incluye todo el
ciclo de desarrollo desde la idea
conceptual hasta su puesta en servicio
se estimó inicialmente en el año 2000
que costaría unos 11.300 millones de
dólares sin embargo los cálculos hoy
apuntan a que el desarrollo de este
gigante de los cielos se tragó más de
30.000 millones de dólares
son cifras estratosféricas y ojo porque
la propia airbus reconoce que la 380
jamás le ha dado beneficios Bueno no es
que no haya generado beneficios es que
por el camino se perdieron miles de
millones de dólares y aquí es donde
llegamos a la segunda cosa que hace
falta para lanzar un nuevo avión Además
del dinero hace falta que exista
obviamente la demanda suficiente Y es
que dados los números que se manejan
unas previsiones mal hechas pueden hacer
que el desarrollo del nuevo avión se
Determine convirtiendo en una auténtica
ruina Pues bien justo aquí llegamos a la
parte más controvertida de este duelo de
Titanes La pregunta es qué ha hecho
airbus mejor que los americanos pues
para muchos estadounidenses Europa con
airbus no es sino competencia desleal
una situación queridos amigos que llegó
a provocar toda una guerra comercial
entre Estados Unidos y el bloque europeo
fijaos Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
acuerdan suspender la disputa comercial
entre airbas y Boeing la disputa
comercial de 17 años es la más larga y
costosa en la historia de la omc los
importadores de Estados Unidos han
pagado más de 1.100 millones de dólares
en aranceles desde que los aranceles en
disputa entraron en vigencia en 2019
según datos de la oficina de aduanas y
protección fronteriza de Estados Unidos
ahora bien queréis saber exactamente en
qué consiste Y por qué se ha producido
este conflicto realmente airbus ha
crecido gracias a un trato de favor por
parte de los gobiernos europeos ha sido
este un ejemplo de competencia desleal Y
qué hay de Estados Unidos Pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
guerra de egos
la disputa comercial entre Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea y entre airbus
y Boeing con la Organización Mundial del
Comercio de por medio tenía una causa
muy clara la financiación Y es que
veréis airbus El fabricante europeo de
aviones ha estado recibiendo desde sus
inicios enormes cantidades de dinero
público para poder afrontar el coste que
tiene el desarrollo de nuevos aviones
pero veamos algunos datos a lo largo de
la historia del consorcio los gobiernos
de Francia Alemania Reino Unido y España
a los que después se sumaron otros han
inyectado toneladas de billetes dinero
en forma tanto de subsidios directos
como de préstamos a intereses
artificialmente bajos o directamente sin
ningún tipo de coste financiero es decir
sin intereses hablamos de ayudas que
pudieran llegar a superar los 15.000
millones de dólares pero cuyo impacto en
el mercado podría según algunos cálculos
rondar los 200.000 millones de dólares
jugando todo esto lógicamente en contra
de la estadounidense voy toda esta
financiación es lo que se denominó como
ayudas de lanzamiento y conforman uno de
los mayores planes de política
Industrial europea durante las últimas
décadas
[Música]
básicamente los estados cubrieron con
estos instrumentos una parte importante
del coste de desarrollo de los primeros
modelos de airbas como el a300 o la
familia de aviones de tamaño medio como
la de la 320 que compite con el Boeing
737 el conflicto viene Porque
inicialmente la idea era que estas
ayudas fueran reduciéndose hasta
desaparecer a medida que hervas fuera
madurando en el mercado y también porque
tendrían que ser devueltas en su
totalidad a medida que cada programa
tuviera beneficios es decir la empresa
iba a ser apoyada con dinero de los
contribuyentes europeos en su despegue
con la expectativa de retornar en un
beneficio mayor
[Música]
vamos básicamente un plan típico de
política Industrial que Seguro seguro
muchos de vosotros veis con buenos ojos
al fin y al cabo airbus fue un éxito y
bueno puede que también penséis que es
mejor dedicar los recursos públicos a
iniciativas como esta que no a otro tipo
de cuestiones digamos más etéreas menos
productivas por supuesto sobre esta
cuestión habría mucho que decir pero de
eso nos encargamos en nuestro canal
hermano en visual economic
El caso es que sea como sea como os
podéis imaginar los estadounidenses no
lo ven con buenos ojos y menos aún si
tenemos en cuenta que ni estas ayudas
terminaron por desaparecer ni airbus ha
devuelto la totalidad de estos préstamos
6 de marzo de 2019 hervas en disputa por
600 millones de dólares en préstamos
impagados utilizados para desarrollar el
a380 según reuters afirma que ya no
tendría que pagar ningún préstamo
Estatal pendiente sobre la 380 porque
los gobiernos habían acordado compartir
el riesgo en el proyecto de
aproximadamente 15.000 millones de euros
ya lo veis estas ayudas de lanzamiento
fueron tan ventajosas que por lo visto
incluían una cláusula por la que si el
programa iba mal y el riesgo era
compartido entre el que presta o sea los
gobiernos y el que recibe airbus es
decir que ambos se repartirían las
pérdidas cosa que por cierto no ocurre
con los beneficios de hecho no es que
airbus pierda dinero a ver si el
programa del a380 fue mal pero la
empresa va viento en popa por ejemplo en
2022 esta empresa obtuvo un beneficio
neto es decir después de impuestos de
más de 4.200 millones de euros mejor
resultado de toda su historia pese a
ello parte de las pérdidas del programa
del a380 Se la han comido los estados y
la verdad no sé si eso tiene mucho
sentido Pero sea como sea lo que está
claro es que a los americanos no les
gusta ni un pelo el cabreo es Monumental
tanto en la serie de The Boeing como
entre los políticos de Washington DC
Bajo su punto de vista los europeos han
estado torpeando su industria
aeronáutica con supuestas ayudas
ilegales y de hecho la omc la
Organización Mundial del Comercio llegó
a fallar que este tipo de préstamos
airbus generaron competencia desleal así
que qué queréis que os diga algo de
razón tenían para poder firmar la paz
con Washington y aceptar las directrices
de la omc la Unión Europea Francia y
España tuvieron que Elevar los intereses
que le cobran airbus por los préstamos
ligados al lanzamiento del a350 uno de
los nuevos programas estrellas del
fabricante europeo ahora bien Esto
echarle el freno porque antes de que
inclinéis la balanza a favor de unos u
otros esperando un poco porque como
solemos insistir aquí en visualpolitik
toda historia tiene al menos dos
versiones Y es que los Yankees tampoco
se han estado comportando precisamente
como hermanitas de la Caridad para nada
de hecho podríamos incluso decir que el
gobierno estadounidense ha sacado de
muchos apuros a Boeing en los últimos
años y lo ha hecho utilizando varias
vías diferentes algunas de ellas por
cierto son consecuencias catastróficas
queréis saber de qué estamos hablando
exactamente queréis conocer las
artimañas de los norteamericanos pues
atentos
[Música]
rescates en diferido
ya os hemos contado que el bus ha
recibido muchísimo dinero por parte de
los contribuyentes europeos dinero que
en muchas ocasiones ha sido perdonado lo
que claramente ha perjudicado a Boeing
en su competencia con airbus Pero qué
hay de los americanos se han quedado
acaso con los brazos cruzados pues
evidentemente no ni uno son tan buenos
ni otros son tan malos Boeing también ha
estado recibiendo miles de millones de
dólares en financiación del gobierno
estadounidense y para muchos también
enormes tratos de favor tratos de favor
que según se apunta mucho ojo Podrían
haber venido en ocasiones de la propia
agencia Federal de Aviación de Estados
Unidos la hasta hace poco muy respetada
fa y el organismo que se encarga de
regular y supervisar todas las
actividades relacionadas con la Aviación
civil en los Estados Unidos pero vale la
pregunta evidentemente es cómo lo han
hecho Cómo ha ayudado a Estados Unidos a
boing pues veréis la forma que ha tenido
y que sigue teniendo el gobierno
norteamericano de financiar a Boeing es
a través de multimillonarios contratos
militares y aeroespaciales contratos que
muchos consideran que se otorgarán
digamos inflado de precio Es decir como
si se tratara de una especie de
subvención encubierta de hecho ojo a los
datos los mayores contratistas de boing
son Ni más ni menos que la NASA el
departamento de defensa y el
departamento de seguridad Nacional de
los Estados Unidos para que os hagáis
una idea tan solo en el año 2016 Boeing
consiguió
23.400 millones de dólares en contratos
públicos de Estados Unidos según los
datos ojos recopilados por la propia
administración de servicios generales y
de hecho en su defensa airbus alega que
los constantes y numerosos contratos que
Boeing recibe por parte del gobierno
estadounidense y de las agencias
públicas son una forma de subsidiar al
gigante americano de la Aviación
pero no sólo eso también están los
supuestos tratos de favor por parte de
la fa que os comentábamos hace un
momento fijaos la
faavió un alto riesgo de accidentes pero
dejó que el Boeing 737 Max siguiera
volando los accidentes del Boeing 737
Max fueron la horrible culminación de
una serie de premisas técnicas cerradas
de los ingenieros de Boeing una falta de
transparencia por parte de la gerencia
de Boeing y una supervisión
extremadamente insuficiente de la faa
informe de la comisión de transporte de
infraestructura de la cámara de
representantes de los Estados Unidos la
faa y Boeing manipularon las pruebas del
737 Max durante la recertificación en
efecto todo apunta a que además del
dinero que Estados Unidos inyecta cada
año en Boeing a través de contratos
También estuvo ayudando a la compañía
dándole digamos ciertas facilidades a la
hora de certificar sus aviones
concretamente tenemos el caso del 737
Max que fue un avión que se diseñó tarde
y mal para competir con el airbus a320
que fue una violanzado prácticamente por
sorpresa y contra el que Boeing se vio
fuera del mercado incapaz de competir
[Aplausos]
Pues bien si estas sospechas se
confirman lo que podemos decir es que el
resultado fue trágico pero ojo que
todavía no hemos terminado porque
todavía no os hemos hablado de los
incentivos fiscales 12 de marzo de 2020
el estado de Washington revoca la
exención de impuestos a favor de Boeing
Estados Unidos espera evitar los
aranceles de la Unión Europea los
cambios eliminarían el ahorro del 40% en
el impuesto de uso y ocupación que
ahorró a Boeing unos 118 millones de
dólares en 2018 según los ingresos
publicados de aviones de pasajeros una
exención fiscal para una empresa en
concreto no son estas cosas ayudas
públicas que también perjudican a la
libre competencia no son acaso un trato
de favor por parte de las
administraciones estadounidenses hacia
Boeing pues lo cierto Es que la
Organización Mundial del Comercio no
sólo falló en contra de airbus también
lo hizo en contra de Los Americanos la
omc dictamina que Estados Unidos no
detuvo las exenciones Fiscales injustas
para Boeing Estados Unidos no había
hecho cumplir una orden de 2012 para
detener los subsidios al fabricante de
aviones de los Estados Unidos a través
de extensiones Fiscales Del estado de
Washington la ventaja competitiva
Abusiva provocó la pérdida de ventas de
los aviones de pasillo único a 320 Neo y
a320co de herbas en cinco campañas de
ventas con lo cual qué queréis que os
diga ambos gigantes han pecado de hacer
lo mismo pero de diferentes maneras Esta
es una historia en la que no hay buenos
ni malos pero sí grandes pajarines los
contribuyentes porque sí vamos a ver
puede ser razonable Apoyar el desarrollo
de grandes proyectos tecnológicos e
industriales Pero quizás las ayudas
tendrían que ser más justas limitadas y
abiertas a más empresas no os parece el
caso queridos amigos es que firmar la
paz comercial por este tema entre
Estados Unidos y Europa no ha sido nada
pero que nada fácil ni tampoco algo que
haya caído del cielo es más ha habido un
motivo que ha jugado un papel
absolutamente clave en el fin de la
guerra entre las dos empresas y los dos
bloques os imagináis cuál puede ser pues
atentos
[Música]
lo que china Unido que no lo separe el
hombre
17 años de guerra entre las dos
principales empresas aviones del mundo
pasan factura al final es algo que
repetimos mucho en visualpolitik Las
Guerras comerciales no suelen beneficiar
a ninguna de las partes y el caso de
Boeing y ervus no es diferente ambos
fabricantes han estado haciendo daño
mutuamente y por extensión se lo pueden
haber hecho al desarrollo de la
industria la guerra entre Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea elevó los costes de
importación y exportación restringió el
uso y el desarrollo de tecnologías y al
final encareció los aviones y ralentizó
la evolución de la industria y sabéis
que esto creó un caldo de cultivo ideal
para que otros intentaran aprovechar el
río revuelto ahora le han visto las
orejas al lobo y sí el lobo es otra vez
china también acordamos trabajar juntos
Unión Europea y Estados Unidos para
desafiar y contrarrestar las prácticas
antimercado de china en este sector que
otorgan a las empresas chinas una
ventaja injusta Joe biden es algo que
también os lo contamos en un pasado
vídeo en nuestra particular serie de
vídeos sobre el mundo de la Aviación el
duopolio airbus boing podría estar
amenazado al menos en el segmento del
corto y medio radio por un nuevo
competidor la china komac
está utilizando agresivamente una mezcla
de las dos formas de subsidios públicos
que hemos visto en este vídeo las
utilizadas por los europeos y las
utilizadas por los americanos el
gobierno chino está subvencionando
directamente el desarrollo de aviones y
esta también realizando enormes pedidos
a través de sus aerolíneas estatales de
hecho el comac arj-21 con capacidad para
hasta 100 pasajeros ya realiza vuelos
comerciales y el comac c919 está en
vuelos de pruebas Aunque ha encontrado
algunos problemas Y puede que su entrada
en servicio se retrase desde lo previsto
para 2023 Lo cierto es que este avión
puede suponer una enorme amenaza para el
futuro de Boeing y de airbus hablamos de
un avión que puede transportar hasta 174
pasajeros y que por tanto compite
directamente con el a320 y el 737 en
China Los buques insignia de los dos
gigantes occidentales es más china
espera fabricar 150 de estos aviones al
año para el 2028
y este escenario el de un fabricante
aeronáutico para el mercado chino de
corto y medio radio sería la peor de las
pesadillas para airbus y Boeing Por qué
Pues porque china es el mercado clave
para el futuro de los dos gigantes de la
aviación de hecho según cálculos de la
propia Boeing el gigante asiático
necesitará comprar mucha atención casi
8.500 nuevos aviones de pasajeros de
aquí a 2041 esto es una verdadera
salvajada con lo que si un competidor
local como komac conseguirá llevarse
aunque sea una parte importante de este
pastel el futuro de Boeing y derbus
podría cambiar por completo un torpedo a
la línea de flotación del negocio Así
que ambas empresas y los gobiernos
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea lo que
han hecho ha sido tirar de pragmatismo
ambas empresas han abierto en los
últimos años líneas de ensamblaje final
en China para algunos de sus modelos más
demandados como el Boeing 737 o los
airbus a320 y a32 Neo además la Unión
Europea ha ofrecido a Estados Unidos
enterrar las dichosas ayudas de
lanzamiento airbus a cambio de financiar
El consorcio a través del gasto militar
algo que ya estamos viendo fijaos España
prestará airbus 2140 millones de euros
para programas militares Sí tal y como
muchos estaréis pensando esto es
prácticamente adoptar el modelo
americano de financiación a Boeing
contra el que durante 17 años ha estado
luchando Bruselas en fin quien los
entienda que los compre
lo que se sabe hasta ahora es que ambos
bloques la ue y Estados Unidos han
firmado una tregua un alto al fuego en
esta guerra comercial la cual en teoría
debería solucionarse antes de 2026 el
futuro pues no lo podemos saber a
ciencia cierta eso nunca pero lo que
está claro es que ni herbos ni Boeing
están en condiciones de echarse
demasiado en cara en cuanto a esto de la
competencia desleal los dos gigantes
industriales han recibido enormes
cantidades de dinero los dos controlan
más o menos una porción parecida del
mercado y los dos tienen enormes
conexiones políticas con el sector
público pero llegados hasta aquí es
turno para ti crees que airbus y Boeing
lograrán firmar la paz de forma
definitiva deberían ambas empresas
empezará a colaborar para evitar que los
chinos abran paso en el mercado Y tú
tienes un favorito Boeing airbus aquí
como puedes ver el a340-600 con la libre
antigua de iberia nos gusta dejanos tus
opiniones aquí abajo en los comentarios
Y no olvides que es hora de aprender ese
idioma que te hace tanta falta con un
50% de descuento en Babel usando el
enlace que encontrarás abajo recuerda
también que si te gusta lo que hacemos
puedes apoyarnos sumándote a nuestra
comunidad en patrón en alguno de los
seis niveles diferentes que tenemos una
vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo hasta la próxima
[Música]